today on our show we're talking about
the mummy not your mummy the Tom Cruise
mommy oh that's good yeah today I
welcome the fat man Batman I'm Kevin
Smith I'm hukman Arden okay man in a
long tradition of us sitting here
watching trailers which we've done only
a couple times now we're gonna watch The
Mummy trailer man the Tom Cruise mummy
tries everything on it is his name above
title Tom Cruise as The Mummy let me
play vampire you think at any point he
was just like being the mummy this is
old hat to me is the vampire the vampire
lestat it's a good mummy I'm it's mostly
CG anyway I'm mostly sand who gives a
[ __ ] it kind of like I've seen the
trailer we've seen the trailer ready but
we're gonna watch it here and you're
gonna watch us watch it you're gonna
watch it watch it you're gonna watch us
watching but I'm watching you like to
watch it dirty cooks the the trailer
though that I've seen here man looks
like a Mission Impossible 9 it really
does it just looks like Mission
Impossible I'm at one point somebody's
like hey man look out for the mummy and
then they're like come on God was
convinced we were watching the curator
showing you him up yet again
um so watch us dive into the mummy who
directed this Alex Kurtzman
he's a JJ boy he's a JJ boy Kurtzman and
Orci he's like JJ boy [ __ ] you fat man
I'm a JJ man I'm a grown-ass person he
come from the JJ school indeed hey man
there's another guy working or slow
burrow or C or C they broke their were
running stars to dodge they wrote the
first two wrote on the first two strikes
I know Damon Lindelof wrote the second
one and I think they had a hand in the
third one the only the first one for
sure yeah and then they also wrote JJ's
like possible for sure I think they were
Mission Possible Jim's a great entry
into that yeah sure all right so one of
them's directing now yeah alex is
directing everybody directed anything
else um I want to say he did a small
movie with Chris Pine
that came out three or four years ago my
time in like Chris Pine and Elizabeth
Banks maybe it's my very small like
indie thing this [ __ ] looks expensive
yeah you don't get Tom Cruise unless you
can spend money you don't get to play
with the mummy unless you're spending
there's unit one at universals Jules yes
this is Emily this is the thing that
will for them kick off their sort of
shared universe of universal mosque
Avengers monster verse adventures
monster verse yes it begins with this
and in the trailer what's his name pops
up Russell Crowe and he's playing dr.
Jekyll like this dr. Jekyll who becomes
mr. Hyde nice so they're starting to
layer their universe they don't have a
vamp Frankenstein or Dracula yet now yet
I mean they had Dracula untold with with
Luke Evans and Dominic Cooper which was
supposed to be the kickoff for their
universal monster cycle but nobody saw
it so they decided to like push ever
yeah we might have done a movie that you
might not have seen because nobody did
yeah by the way did you see Jurassic
world in fact some three or seven you
saw those right was the same year same
here Wow
yeah ajan being a universal film the
same year as those movies we really we
happen to know you didn't really you're
adorable how long now back to the corner
um well this looks like somebody [ __ ]
game a few pennies to make this flick it
looks expensive yes uh and it looks like
there's a lot going on let's break it
down let's digest it shall we
ah bite-sized chunk trailers queued up
folks here we go
bring mark diving deep into your mommy
Universal logo man planets good things
glads whoo I'm gonna spice up Ron Z of
Dark Knight The Dark Knight Rises
who's the girl I don't know who's the
guy Tom Cruise I win this round that
looked oh yes a coffee kiss man minun
minun
daddy made man than him in a minute he's
haunted by this Miss segundus is it was
like Courtney B Vance yeah mmm Talent
I still know the laborers nope this skin
looks great in the clothes that runs
right what huh oh [ __ ] yeah this is
basically Mission Impossible six is that
impressive to you watching people like
photo and less than you think
less than I think they think we think I
mean I'm like I get it but it's I would
rather up and talk hmm but that's not
gonna get and then those sequences go
hopefully it's this long in the movie
and now this is where things get funky
yeah like so he's he dead and if he get
mummified you know so he is them not bad
for an old man Tom Cruise and then looks
good right
keep taking a shirt off
yeah it's a confidence ma'am in the
minimum of men in the minimum in math
and monsters to add your iris to people
let's go
please meet princess that's doctor
jeopardy
she looks awesome who is the mummy sofia
boutella
she was there in Kingsman she was the
girl with their razor feet Oh does she
not have raised a few real life I don't
believe her
well I'm an idiot I thought that was
real not this the razor for that guy um
look I'm him I'll [ __ ] see that
dude I've said it before I'll say it
again Tom Cruise running is one of the
best special effects in movies just what
is he doing [ __ ] sprinting how old is
he
I need years old he's gonna get there
before you will because he's [ __ ] Tom
Cruise Tom Cruise is living proof that
you do anything with as much gusto and
passion as if you're saving the universe
you'll you'll be happy at your job and
live forever like Ramon he pours it into
everything do you think name one
performance that he phones in where his
ever phone dude yeah I don't think he's
ever done in your voice work and and can
you even think of a sequel where you're
like well I wasn't strong and I mean
even the Mission Impossible he's always
like strapped me to a plane he like
lately always up for giving the shitty
movies even like legend which is not
good well I love it but it's not good
yeah he's still devoted to it he's still
given it wears on y'all like talk about
that movie though no not so much no not
anymore ever I like even back then I
think they had a fight Shaymin really
but Tim Curry's dope in that movie dude
where is like I am on auto plants in
space job um yeah I'm in man Tom Cruise
legitimising a [ __ ] mummy flick like
that
that's dope I will win somewhere Brendan
Fraser's like ah I was a mummy first
yeah I was monkey bone and it all went
bad no he had the [ __ ] monkey bone
happened then the mummy Saturday Lee oh
yeah Frasier was like he was at first he
had like Encino man
and then like monkey bone happened later
but then these kid member yet Dudley
do-right then these happen the mummy
movies happened not to use the other
mummy movies and he was like top dog for
a while then after the mummy franchise
was over
ready head was like Journey to the
Center of the Earth which does it really
well really well um but yeah do you
think is there even a like courtesy like
hey you want to come play pop openness
II know I would if I was Universal
ability money kept the franchise alive
for a long let me play a waiter in one
scene
don't give me the lessees a haunted
waiter who must be firstly we're running
from here to Cairo would you like
something to drink like can you not look
at the camera will do that please I
don't know how not to do that I'm
Brendan Fraser I'm the star of the mummy
um I think I would have given him a
[ __ ] spot you think's out how [ __ ]
yeah I would have made him a part of the
team or some says [ __ ] i bored unlike an
old scene where like they tied into that
mummy movie where he's an old man now an
old man make up and you just rather than
when I fought the mummy yes he's a be
careful Tom Cruise and then [ __ ]
curses I'm kind of a [ __ ] I'm in
romantic like you are instead the job
that he will get it's like craft
services cool Brendan Fraser can you
bake a muffin Brendan Fraser's Richard
and Rosabelle from the mummy movies has
to be right they made like a TCU you
would think what people have made them
decision with money in Hollywood in the
past not Brendan Fraser you know what
saying about him this is about the back
it's not about Mary Fraser
it's not about bravery so mark can't be
about Brendan Fraser periodically will
says you this trailer is pretty [ __ ]
cool I'm on going I'm on board man but
like like more show me dr. Jekyll I
don't even need to see mr. Hyde but like
show me your Frankenstein show me your
Dracula like tease me man
that's dope I like this as long as we
don't get the like dr. Jekyll goes to
his laptop and looks at files for other
Universal Monsters
like look somebody made a logo for the
Wolfman logo for Dracula would be too
fast you [ __ ] or liking it with lips
wolf man would just be the moon good one
with the W in front of it what now what
was the moon with uh oh pro-ice like a
smile lamb and yes and then Frank Stein
would just be bolts that would be pretty
good in the neck dr. Jekyll mr. Hyde
it would just be like that half and half
like you just see like little guy and I
your would I just mastered a little
Invisible Man we need you for that just
type it's pipe floating in the air it's
in a quick little beat during a montage
you're sure you know what the universal
monsters are missing ladies well like
yeah it's right you got to introduce a
Frankenstein before you get to a Bride
of Frankenstein but they but they just
think I'm like The Mummy yeah they're
like [ __ ] you mark barnard we're leading
with a lady I feel like maybe you do the
wolf lady I would I would watch a
Wolfman was that your tragedy that's my
pitch new tell us not bad the wolf woman
and the wolf on them you still called
the wall phone or you call it the wolf
man I think you call like you still got
the Walkman of your called maybe just
call it wolf they did that once right
Nicholson Nicholson
yeah but [ __ ] him get they also did
the mummy nineteen times so that's curse
of the werewolf you could do that then I
bet then it's gender-neutral
right see see we're writers finger and
[ __ ] on right and right in front yeah
that's what it looks like so writing
looks like yes you were just gonna write
his room for a movie we're never gonna
get to write but we thought it
nobody's digging our suggestion oh um
I'm in man I'm in yeah I'm in [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah it's got my money
I honestly I'll see almost anything Tom
Cruise does he's committed man pop
committed he's one of the last Matt
looks like finished you're absolutely
right there's another reason yes uh
there it is man we watched The Mummy and
you watched us watching the money and
that's it that's our teamwork for hey
thanks for hanging out here in the fact
cave with me and Mark ah forefront Matt
Batman I've been Kevin Smith I've been
Marvin are come back next time man we'll
talk about some more goofy [ __ ] same fat
time same fat channels marques calm or
youtube.com slash Kevin Smith
you